we had a ditch next to our house  like a big ditch  i mean a ditch it was just a ditch and  and i hated my neighborhood so much and  i would sit down  sit out and just stare into the ditch in  the cold  when i was in third grade i just sit up  there  what  that's the story  that you looked in the ditch i would  stare into it for hours what were you  hoping come out like pan's labyrinth  there was nothing to do dude it was it  was i was what i would argue  i would argue a peak depression time in  my life third grade  oh my god  that's sad yeah  i would have maybe maybe would go  because it was a good start i thought  you were gonna at least say you rolled  around a ditch you took some tonka  trucks you rolled them down and up the  ditch you just stared at me there was a  little creak in it that i fell in once  or twice  wait a minute how long did your  relationship with the ditch go on  that ditch was a huge part of my  childhood